Have you ever wanted to be a cartoon?
They have it easier than we do, that’s for
sure.
The characters in your favorite shows never
seem to experience boring days, and the world
around them always seems so wonderful and
imaginative.
Animation is an idealized, stylized form of
reality, where anything can happen, and entertainment
is at the forefront of the lived experience.
If you’re understanding the appeal behind
what we’re talking about, you’ll definitely
be interested in hearing about SCP-6080, a
strange anomaly known as Eric’s Cartoon
Box.
The story of Eric’s Cartoon Box is elaborate
and complex, but catalogs one of the Foundation’s
most imaginative and surreal anomalies on
file.
It started on Parawatch.net, a message board
dedicated to the supernatural and paranormal
that the Foundation likes to keep tabs on
in their spare time.
While sifting through countless fake posts
about being abducted by aliens or hunting
for bigfoot, the Foundation noticed something
less conventional that caught their eye.
A series of posts that talked about a “cursed”
VHS tape of the mid-90s classic Nickelodeon
cartoon “Rocko’s Modern Life”.
Now, a cursed cartoon seems like your standard
internet horror fiction fare, something the
Foundation could easily dismiss as a story
crafted by an amateur author, but what caught
their attention were the pictures of strange
entities that appeared as a result of watching
the tape, as well as information on how the
original poster obtained the tape.
It seemed oddly specific.
A tape purchased on eBay through a seller
named “tooncollector”.
The Foundation conducted a brief investigation,
and found that “tooncollector” was a resident
of Bakersfield, California named Jacob Sawyer,
who had gone missing some time in the past.
Inside his house, the Foundation found several
VHS tapes and DVD cases, as well as a television.
A hard drive on Sawyer’s computer contained
161 hours of brief, edited videos, all reviewing
and commentating on various cartoons.
Seems like Sawyer had a video essay hobby,
but the Foundation was unable to locate any
of this content on major video hosting sites.
In Sawyer’s basement, the Foundation discovered
a large, worn-out cardboard box.
On its right side were the words “Eric’s
Cartoon Box”, written in black sharpie.
On its front was a simplistic smiley face,
also drawn in sharpie.
Originally, the Foundation thought it was
just an ordinary box, but the object quickly
proved itself to be alive, capable of speaking
despite a lack of vocal cords and also possessing
a degree of mobility, propelling itself short
distances to move.
When the Foundation first came across SCP-6080
in Sawyer’s basement, the object was clearly
distressed.
SCP-6080 and all of the other items found
were taken into Foundation custody, and moved
to Site-433, where they would be researched
by Dr. Rowan Raster, one of the Foundation’s
leading figures in the study of animated anomalous
media and art.
Raster’s research found that SCP-6080, when
emotionally distressed, could bend reality
to alter their surroundings, which were transformed
into reflections of its psyche.
Raster discovered that there were a few ways
to pacify SCP-6080, but the most practical
method was to evoke a sense of nostalgia in
the object by placing it in a familiar environment.
To ensure that the box is kept passive, SCP-6080
is kept inside a containment chamber resembling
a child’s bedroom, an environment SCP-6080
finds comforting.
On top of their reality-bending abilities,
SCP-6080 also produces DVDs and VHS tapes,
labeled SCP-6080-1.
The Foundation would later discover that the
tapes found within Sawyer’s home and the
“cursed” Rocko’s Modern Life tape discussed
on Parawatch.net were all products of SCP-6080.
But what’s so special about the cartoon
reproductions made by SCP-6080?
On the outside, they’re unaltered copies
of animated children’s television shows
and films, and their contents are exactly
the same as their ordinary counterparts.
However, once an instance of SCP-6080-1 is
viewed, the subject watching it will experience
a reality-altering anomalous experience dubbed
by the research team as a “Rerun Event”.
Sometimes, the Rerun Event occurs immediately,
though research has shown that as much time
as 3 weeks can pass before one occurs.
Rerun events often reflect visual or thematic
elements of the media that induced them, and
their severity ranges from inconsequential
to dangerous and harmful to their subjects.
Because of the variety found in a Rerun Event’s
content, it’s difficult to generalize them,
but we’ll be sure to get into the specifics
of a few later on.
Still, even if the Event isn’t immediately
dangerous to the subject, the Foundation discovered
that a Rerun Event may leave involved persons
with lingering physical and psychological
alterations, some of which are unable to be
fully alleviated or treated, even with amnestics.
Soon after SCP-6080 was brought into Site-433
and the immediate characteristics of the anomaly
were recorded, an interview between the box
and Researcher Rowan Raster was held.
Rowan tried to make sure the anomaly was as
comfortable as possible, but SCP-6080 continued
to shuffle against the floor rapidly, unsettled
in their new environment.
SCP-6080 wanted to get out, and the object
continued to stress themselves out, to the
point where its speech degraded into unintelligibility,
the lights in the containment chamber began
flickering on and off, and the face on the
front of the box rapidly flipped between different
expressions.
Rowan continued trying to get through to SCP-6080,
and eventually they began to speak.They said
that they were scared, and that they missed
someone that they called Eric.
SCP-6080, once calmed down, explained that
Eric was the center of their universe.
In their own words, SCP-6080 felt, when it
first started existing, that their sole purpose
for being here on earth was to exist for Eric.
They remembered waking up in a bedroom filled
with toys and posters, and immediately knowing
the feeling that they knew what they were
made for and who they were made by.
At first, this was overwhelming, and SCP-6080
began to freak out, but Eric showed concern,
and the box realized that they didn’t want
to upset him.
The most important thing for SCP-6080 was
to not upset Eric.
When Raster asked if they could describe Eric,
the box was unable to, and said that whenever
they tried to talk about Eric’s appearance,
people became confused.
They said that Eric’s skin was blue, and
that he had a purple nose, with dark red eyes
and four thin strands of hair on the top of
his head.
From the way they described Eric, he sounded
exactly like a cartoon character.
Raster asked if this was how SCP-6080 always
saw people, and that seemed to be the case.
SCP-6080 then explained how they used their
abilities to make Eric happy, namely through
producing tapes of Eric’s favorite cartoons
and then playing inside the worlds of the
shows together.
And this continued for a while.
SCP-6080 and Eric would meet the characters
from their favorite shows and adventure through
their worlds, and the two developed a powerful
bond.
But eventually, as SCP-6080 explained, Eric
left.
One day, the box woke up, and their friend
was gone.
SCP-6080 even searched for Eric’s friends,
but found that they were gone too.
Without Eric, SCP-6080 was alone, and they
panicked.
They ran outside the house and began asking
anyone they could find if they knew where
Eric went.
Naturally, the people SCP-6080 spoke to were
terrified.
And SCP-6080 quickly became overwhelmed by
the chaos of the outside world.
And then they found Jacob Sawyer.
Sawyer was, at first, just as scared of SCP-6080
as everyone else was.
But once SCP-6080 opened its flaps and revealed
a trove of old tapes, Sawyer smiled to himself,
and told the box that it would be “useful”,
before picking them up and taking them to
his house.
SCP-6080 was scared, and attempted to flee
from Sawyer.
The more time the box spent with Sawyer, the
sicker it felt.
When Sawyer threw the box in the empty, white
walls of his basement, SCP-6080 was forced
by Jacob to open themselves up and produce
tapes.
For months, this is how SCP-6080 lived.
Alone, in a white-walled room, with white
floors and white ceilings.
Being forced open and used as a dispenser
for the tapes, which Sawyer would sell online.
SCP-6080 stopped their account, and began
crying a substance that resembled blueberry
syrup.
Raster put a stop to the interview, realizing
that the object was clearly experiencing a
form of trauma.
After a break, Raster asked SCP-6080 if they
knew what happened to Sawyer.
The box explained that one day, Sawyer rushed
down into the basement, and demanded SCP-6080
to explain what it was doing to the cartoons
it made.
Apparently, some of the buyers were realizing
that SCP-6080’s tapes were anything but
normal.
Sawyer brutalized the box, and pulled a DVD
from inside them.
But when Sawyer watched the DVD for himself,
all SCP-6080 heard from beneath the living
room was a sharp burst of static and a horrible
scream.
After that, Jacob was gone.
SCP-6080 couldn’t recall what tape they
produced that caused Sawyer to disappear,
nor was one matching the box’s description
found inside the house.
After the interview, the Foundation began
its testing with SCP-6080 inside its containment
chamber.
SCP-6080 would produce a tape, a D-Class personnel
would watch it, and the ensuing “Rerun Event”
was recorded.
During testing, SCP-6080 was escorted from
the room so as to not cause it emotional distress.
Most of these tests were routine.
A D-Class would watch an episode of a cartoon,
such as ChalkZone or the Rugrats, and strange,
reality-altering events would occur.
For example, after watching an episode of
the Rugrats where Chuckie had difficulty differentiating
his dreams from reality, D-1711 experienced
a Rerun Event in which he was disoriented.
D-1711 claimed everything in the room looked
“tall”, and that they needed to sleep
off the effects of the anomaly.
After laying in the bed, the chamber’s lights
turned blue and purple, and a humanoid entity
wearing a researcher’s outfit was seen facing
the corner of the room, against the wall.
The figure disappeared as quickly as it appeared,
with laughter heard in the distance.
As soon as the figure was gone, D-1711 jolted
awake, and began screaming.
After this, the researcher observing the experiment
rushed in, and like a concerned parent, began
comforting D-1711.
The researcher assured the D-Class that “nothing
in a dream could hurt them, because it isn’t
real” which was a direct quote from the
Rugrats episode D-1711 watched.
After this, the D-Class and the researcher
came out of their trance state, wondering
how they got inside the containment chamber
and what they were doing there.
The Rerun event had finished, and D-1711 explained
that while they were asleep, they dreamed
events similar to the dreams shown in the
Rugrats episode.
This is just one example of how odd and surreal
rerun events can be.
Another test involving an obscure cartoon
by the name of “King”, resulted in the
entirety of Site-433 undergoing changes that
made it look as if it were a location from
the show itself.
However, the most notable rerun event occurred
when the Foundation tested a tape of “Cartoon
All Stars to the Rescue”, a special featuring
cartoon characters from various shows banding
together to talk about the dangers of children
using drugs.
In order to conduct this test, D-9926 was
sent to a quarantined community away from
Site-433, with only a helmet-mounted camera
and a communication headset. 10 hours after
watching the tape, D-9926 slept inside a bedroom
of the vacant building the Foundation had
brought him to.
He was woken by the sound of the doorknob
jittering, and then several knocks.
D-9926 got up from the bed and opened the
door to find four crude-looking entities resembling
cartoon characters from the special.
One was Kermit the Frog, who was puppeteered
by a man in a gray hoodie.
Another was a cardboard cutout of Bugs Bunny.
There was a tall, mascot-like Garfield costume,
and a sentient ALF plush.
The four entities crowded D-9926 and began
singing to him in a shrill, high pitched voice
a song about the dangers of doing drugs.
D-9926 was confused, but the trance induced
by the anomaly made it difficult for him to
think straight.
Then, from the open windowsill in the room
came a black boot attached to a long leg.
A fifth entity made its way into the room,
crawling through the windowsill.
It was a tall, gray-skinned humanoid with
wrinkled trousers, a creased shirt, and a
large necktie.
As much as D-9926 could understand, the gray
entity was not from a cartoon.
The gray entity signaled D-9926 towards them,
and the two left the building and the strange
cartoon entities behind.
Outside, the environment was strange, it was
dark out, with only dim street lights illuminating
the spaces between trees at a low angle.
The asphalt path the duo walked on slowly
transitioned to a field of grass.
The gray entity explained that the very nature
of the environment was built around the message
of the cartoon, which was trying to get D-9926
to avoid using drugs.
Somehow, D-9926 needed to find a way to get
out.
As the two moved through the forest area,
D-9926 and the Gray Entity continued to recognize
something was wrong.
Gray explained that it didn’t understand
where they were either, and that when D-9926’s
rerun event began altering reality, it was
pulled away from the place it regularly existed,
and into reality.
D-9926 did not understand, but he was short
on options.
Both of them smelled something horrible, and
the area around them was starting to resemble
the real world less and less.
The sky above the forest was smokey orange-red,
and in the distance, D-9926 could see a luminescent
object resembling a window recessed into a
concrete wall.
The two also heard music, and as they moved
through this dream-like world, they came across
the building in the distance, which was small
enough for them to climb the roof of.
On the roof, there appeared to be a parking
lot, and beyond it, more forest, as if they
never elevated from the ground in the first
place.
The two continued walking.
As the parking lot sloped downwards, they
recognized what appeared to be a city in the
distance.
D-9926 knew that with the altered state of
reality, this city was going to be anything
but normal, but he felt compelled to keep
moving.
It was the only thing the two of them could
do.
D-9926 and the Gray Entity began talking about
the nature of the reality they found themselves
in, and the entity explained that it felt
that trusting its gut and exploring anything
that stood out was probably the right thing
to do in a place that made little actual sense.
They concluded that the location they were
inside had some sort of feelings and goals,
and they just had to go along with its own
internal logic in order to find a way out.
In the distance, the red lights of the city
twinkled in the darkness.
They continued walking.
After about 30 minutes, the red lights of
the city illuminated all of their surroundings,
and they began to see the edifices of concrete
buildings on the other side of the road they
were walking on.
D-9926 didn’t notice them at first, but
when the entity pointed them out, D-9926 realized
they were standing in the middle of a mass
of buildings, with rubble and litter strewn
on the streets beneath them.
Gray wondered if they could use them as shelter.
The two didn’t realize they were being watched
by a figure in the distance.
D-9926 was still confused.
The city was empty, Gray seemed oddly optimistic
about their situation, and things weren’t
looking like they were going to return to
normal any time soon.
Gray commented that they were somewhat interested
in exploring a location different from the
realities and dreams they were used to exploring.
After minutes of nothing, the duo came across
a dead body, laying on top of a rusted metal
wheelbarrow.
D-9926, who was familiar with seeing sights
like these, sighed and continued moving.
Gray told him he could simply walk away, into
the darkness, where they could forget about
this place and emerge somewhere else.
D-9926 wondered if the entity really had that
power.
They came across more bodies, and continued
forward.
If this entity could really whisk D-9926 away
to another place, he was seriously considering
it.
Life as a D-Class was unimaginably dehumanizing.
The figure watching the two of them continued
to observe from a rooftop.
Suddenly, a large sheet metal shelving unit
fell from the overhanging roof of a building,
tipped from its edge by the observing figure.
The shelving unit hit Gray directly, and severely
injured the entity on impact.
D-9926 ran.
He ran through the buildings, only catching
glimpses of the orange figure wielding a thick
pipe running across the rooftops beside him.
The chase continued through the insides of
the buildings, and once D-9926 caught a glimpse
of the pursuing figure, he ran back out.
The entire time, he heard the figure’s high
pitched breathing audibly chasing after him.
More bodies, more red lighting, an endless
city, all while being pursued.
D-9926 found rest inside a warehouse, which
he ran through in an attempt to escape the
entity.
At the far side of the warehouse was a room
resembling SCP-6080’s containment chamber,
but heavily damaged and littered with trash.
The television set in the room switched on,
showing an all white room, similar to the
basement SCP-6080 was found in.
The door to the room was about to be opened,
and D-9926 screamed, before smashing the TV
with a book he threw from across the room.
Upon shattering the screen, the camera feed
went dark.
When it resumed, D-9926 found himself in a
red, misty area, with the figure that had
been pursuing him standing in front of him.
The two stared at each other before the figure
lunged forward at D-9926.
But it then suddenly stopped, and the voice
of SCP-6080 was heard.
The box called out to the figure, which it
recognized as something that resembled Jacob
Sawyer.
SCP-6080 ordered the Sawyer-entity to leave
D-9926 alone.
Except this time, SCP-6080 wasn’t a cardboard
box.
They were a pale-skinned child, drawn like
a cartoon, wearing ordinary clothes.
The box realized that this place was a manifestation
of its own traumatic experience as it slowly
realized that the entity resembling Sawyer
was stuck inside its own mind.
The box and the entity fought each other,
punching with large, cartoon-like fists.
Until the Sawyer-entity fell to the ground,
coughing up blood.
SCP-6080 realized that this wasn’t actually
Sawyer.
Like everything, this was all a manifestation
of the damage that Sawyer caused.
And with that, the entity left its own body,
flattening until all that was left was its
empty skin.
D-9926 thanked SCP-6080 for saving him, and
the two introduced themselves to one another.
SCP-6080 offered to take D-9926 away from
the Foundation forever.
He took off his recording equipment, and the
two walked away into the sunset.
Inside SCP-6080’s containment chamber, the
object, and D-9926, were nowhere to be found.
Instead, there was a single disc, containing
a message from SCP-6080 to the Foundation.
SCP-6080 told the Foundation that they were
coming to terms with what they experienced
in their life, and that for now, they were
in a place where they could exist without
issue.
Behind them was a playground, where SCP-6080
could act like a kid again, something they
never got to experience as much as they wanted
to.
They told the Foundation that D-9926 was safe,
and happy somewhere else, and that they shouldn’t
look for either of them, because they’d
never find them.
For now, all SCP-6080 needed to do was to
play on the swings, and live at peace with
themselves, until they could grow up.
Inside the disc that the message was contained
on was a sticky note that simply read:
“I hope you understand.”
Now go check out “SCP-3082 - Neverland's
Lost Boys and Girls” and “SCP-974 - Treehouse
Predator” for more of the SCP Foundation’s
anomalous child’s play!